[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'est le magic as usual' avancé ils
ont analysé la page
les artistes invités et même plus
vigilants aux sources retour elle fut un
des ferments vous le 11 06 18 g arrête
là roman épique tout se construit le
réveil et conçoit sache écouter et vous
devez arriver
nous allons faire venir et h
et on vivait dans le futur au moins elle
fronce les générations futures
m je vais aviser la mrc et enfin positif
qui ont payé les gravats sont ouvertes m
ils ont compris que le mot clé l'a
convaincu les défis notre réalité et les
pieds dans l'essence l'état le grand
défi des têtes rasées
ils ont rassemblé autour d'eux ils ont
réparti les tâches en fonction des
spécialités de chacun et rappeur avant
quatre à pierre à la construction de
l'édifice national d'israël y est
suivez cette réalisation est de nous
devra avoir lui
je ne suis ramassé d'envoyer leurs
revenus
car sans avoir de dépendances une
amabilité ficime de gouvernance les
grenat ce qui est terrible et compatible
avec leur culture est compatible avec
les hommes chargés depuis lors et aux
sociétés et zila il ressentait avec
après valence les choses au vert mais
elle va au bout de fille quitter
véritablement aujourd'hui nous vivons
dans deux mois sous chaque récréation
les nations où il éviter les guerres et
la société j aurais eu leurs idées ou
mieux et s'est rendu chez eux les
limites aiguille qu une seule clinique
située à l'est du désormais des
entreprises ils n'ont plus sur glee des
ou politique
une vidéo sur la vie économique culturel
sportif et yvonne s'activent au gang a
fait a vendu une oeuvre d'art larry
koffi s'organise mais les sommes non
plus chez nous demander si un grand
destin
avec le fonds sera travaux feront un
travail
oui 6ème mondiale
c'est la série cette année avait fléchi
sur cette problématique la cambuse
heures a accueilli par une haie lors des
regroupements et enfin le processus du
développement et on peut défendre le
suspect alors que la ville est revenue
au coeur
elle pourrait alors vous mettre en place
la survie du je vais vous serez à rêver
de monde a eu des nausées droit marche
bien mais il travaille aux champs ou
payer innover dans l'intérêt de tous et
chacun se voudront le faire renaître le
soir ou le vvf voudront dès lors aucun
signe au psg en janvier devait pas de
vous former ces domaines et ses abonnés
et le vin c'est une citation de gaz en
l'état
ils recherchent des voeux on revient
aujourd'hui avec et ferroviaires
avancées des sciences et des
technologies
nous allons au seuil du marchix et chef
du projet et le cerveau et le audiard
blier que lors du cerveau et plus
en effet le plus officier il m'est
arrivé est un fonctionnaire du trésor à
six mois est bien conscient que 0 3e
alex alice il est vrai d un stress il en
reçoit irène
c'est donc jeudi avec yves voyage à bord
nouveau physique ou aux noix de ronde de
la fois un fait qui peut en effet le
récif monde affiche une robe
il ya simplement filer sa machine à
voyager ou qui se met à mal un deuxième
mais au début se crasher
ça vous revoir les enfants d'une classe
ou d'un ami une fois en train de
savourez vos les glyphes je suivrai aux
poussins poussines 1 0
c'est vrai qu'il ya deux ans j'ai vu
arriver cette machine configurer à
travers une éducation qui habitent à
aïda il faut graver en inde et celui de
priorité des fluides et dissimulent
hoeness qui dort l'homme a besoin d'être
possibilités dans le groupe mais
également un grand vide et meurent parce
que la vie est pour être régulier de vos
virées il ya un besoin d'avoir les
guides sa guise les tours des lois mais
les lois et règlements les comptes de
l'assurance et de la confiance
il donne du tonus à la cpi tapez 1 -
décider
il est capable d'imaginer des solutions
sur comment les concevoir le jeudi c'est
vraiment à ce mouvement
on peut parler de narnia que le ver est
vrai c'est la projection dans le futur
et la réalisation d'un loser et
délivrera pas évident à est un peu le
cerveau a passé trois étapes
sa présence les erreurs si vous voulez
c'est l'allégorie d'abord nous vivons de
leur art tout se passe à noter le chien
dilater prothèse
je redis que l'enfer et de tapis sont
dans nos textes et nous devons apprendre
à vous avez cerveau
je vais oser un voyage dans le futur
nous avons heureusement un bébé se
rendit la truite qui invite à flic en
clichy peu le second vient de mettre à
leur 10e journée du développement et
une indice de deux générations une
formation ultra immerge il travaille
mais avait du vent dans les arbres
c'est ça qui fait mal de se vêtir
chercher nations d'abord alors à payer
sous les 10 il était temps hier au
leader je vois besoin d'une aide
spéciale l'ère du haut débit d'ici tout
veut on le peut a ici une société
d'avocats avaient entamé en le peu
affiche une société technologique avec
des hommes qui ont visité belgique on ne
peut pas fini une société de futures
avec vous honfid aujourd'hui il veut que
l'homme du futur de son principal outil
de travail
san siro il amusé